hey everyone i welcome you all to simply
learn
in this session we will discuss about
two important parametric tests that are
z test and t test and what are the major
difference between them
we'll also work out on an example
to understand
how the z value and the critical value
plays an important role in the
hypothesis testing
so without further delay let's begin
we'll start by discussing what is
hypothesis testing and what is the
importance of null hypothesis
then we'll discuss the example for the
same and then we'll move on to z test
and t test and understand the difference
and the major points regarding it
so what is hypothesis testing
a statistical hypothesis is an
assumption about the population
parameters
this assumption may or may not be true
hypothesis testing refers to the formal
procedures used by statisticians to
accept or reject the statistical
hypothesis
here the alternate hypothesis is usually
your initial hypothesis that predicts
the relationship between the two
variables
for example
suppose you answer the question how many
hours per day are students play outdoor
sports
with this data you can make a hypothesis
students who spend more time on outdoor
activities stays fit
in this hypothesis testing there is one
major term that is null hypothesis
a null hypothesis expresses the opposite
of what researcher or experiments
predicts or anticipates
it essentially defines the statement
that no exact or actual relationship
exists between the variables
usually it is denoted by h naught
let's try to understand the research and
null hypothesis with the help of an
example
suppose the research hypothesis says the
amount of time that is spent on a
cricket practice results in a positive
performance in an actual cricket match
so in accordance with it a null
hypothesis can be that the amount of
practice is not positively related to
the performance in a cricket match
now that we know about the null and
research hypothesis let's move on to z
test so what is that test
a z test is a statistically significant
test for hypothesis testing
it is used to analyze whether the two
population means are different or not
when the variances are known and the
sample size is very large
in this the sample size should be
usually more than 30
and when the z distribution is normal
the mean is zero and the variance is one
there are few assumptions that we take
into consideration when calculating the
z-test
the first one is all the observations
are independent
there are majorly three steps in the
hypothesis testing the first one is
state the null and alternate hypothesis
and perform the statistical test and
with the help of a z value
we can accept or reject the null
hypothesis
let's discuss this more clearly with the
help of an example
but before that let's discuss the
formula so to calculate the z value we
have this formula that is x bar minus mu
divided by sigma divided by root n
where x bar represents the sample mean
and the sigma is the population standard
deviation
n is the sample size and we use the
population mean
let's see how you can use this formula
to arrive at a null or alternative
hypothesis
let's say that the mean score of
students in a class is greater than 70
with a standard deviation of 10.
if the sample of 50 students was
selected with a mean score of 80 we have
to calculate a z value to check if
there's enough evidence to support this
claim at 0.05 significance level
so
let's point down the important data we
have the x bar that is sample mean equal
to 80. the sigma is given to be 70 that
is the population standard deviation and
is the sample size which is equal to 50
and mu is the population mean that is
equal to 10 putting all the values into
the formula
we get that value to be 7.09
now at the significance level of 0.05
the critical value is 1.645 which is
calculated with the help of a z table
you can get this z table simply by
searching in google
so we have a z value to be 7.09 and the
critical value to be 1.645
since 7.09 is greater than 1.645 we can
simply reject the null hypothesis and
come to a conclusion that there is
enough evidence to support that the mean
of the class is greater than 70.
this is how you can use a z value to
arrive at a proper conclusion
now let's move on to t-test
t-test statistics is a method of testing
hypothesis about the mean of a small
sample drawn from the normally
distributed population
when the population standard deviation
is not known
in this case the data is continuous
the formula to calculate a t value is x
bar minus mu divided by s divided by
root n
where x bar is the sample mean s is the
sample standard deviation n is the
sample size and mu is the population
mean
let's discuss with the help of an
example
suppose the store wants to improve its
sales the previous sales data shows that
the average sales of thirty percent was
forty dollar per sale
after some corporate training the
current data showed an average sale of
dollar sixty per transaction
as the standard division is given to be
twenty dollar we have to calculate the t
value and we have to arrive at a
conclusion that did training improve the
sales or not
so in this case we have the sample mean
to be 60 standard deviation to be 20 the
sample size is taken as 30 and the
population mean is 40.
putting all the values in the formula
will arrive at a value of 5.47
in this case also we assume the
significance value to be 0.05
now moving from right to left in a z
table
the critical value will come out to be
1.711
which is less than 5.47 so in this case
also we can reject the null hypothesis
and we can conclude that the training
did affect the sales
and the training was helpful
so with this we come to an end to this
tutorial i hope this tutorial was useful
for you and you understood what is that
test and t-test is and how it can be
used if yes do subscribe to our channel
so that you never miss an update thank
you again and happy learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here